michigan governor gretchen whitmer is
co-chair of the presidential inaugural
committee
governor whitmer is in washington too
governor whitmer we thank you so much
for joining us so close but yet so far
really appreciate you taking the time so
you're part of glad to be here
yeah we're listen we're very glad to be
here too
you're part of a bipartisan group of
governors that is going to the
inauguration today
why do you think it's so important to
show that type of unity on this
particular day it's been such a
rough and tumble nasty campaign bruce
feelings bruce
it has been it's been difficult it's
been vitriolic it's been dangerous
and yet we as a nation recognize the
transfer of power
today is an important moment it is
certainly in the middle of a
pandemic it is in the middle of what
we've seen in terms of domestic terror
threats and yet
we must move forward and i know that joe
biden is the right person at the right
time kamala harris to be his
right hand i just think that this is a
chance for us
to really talk about how we unify this
nation how we take on domestic terrorism
how we
address racial inequity and get our kids
back in school and
get our people back to work but it
starts with getting our arms around this
virus and i know that's
precisely what joe biden and kamala
harris will be talking about and that
impacts us
i want to talk about the unity question
governor for just a second because as
you know president trump
is not going to the inauguration today a
large group of his supporters
do not believe that he is even a
legitimate president
to the united states so how do you unite
the country when there is a
a large chunk of people who do not
believe
the facts well it's not going to happen
overnight but it starts with having a
leader
who speaks to our common ground and our
ideals and does the hard work of
reaching out
as difficult it's incredibly hard in
this moment however
uh it's more important than ever we have
a common enemy that is a virus
we have to rally to this cause had the
the current occupant of the white house
rallied us to this we would have saved
untold number of lives and
be in a much stronger position
economically he didn't do that
now the hard work is even harder for the
biden harris administration but i know
that they are up to this task and it
starts with that outreach which it
begins in earnest the day after he was
elected uh
president and and continues today the
day he has sworn in as president
you know a lot of states have had
trouble with the uh covid vaccine
distribution how is it going in your
state do you have what you need
no i know state has what we need
unfortunately the trump administration
just like
ppe and testing did not have a national
strategy when it came to
vaccine administration and we are
we're running out of vaccines every day
that's people want to get this vaccine
but we need access to vaccines we're
getting about 60 000 a week
we want to do 50 000 a day so we need a
lot more and i'm
i'm hopeful at this next administration
and i'm confident that they will be able
to get us what we need so we can get
people
um inoculated and eradicate this virus
once and for all
and governor whitner whitmer i'm curious
about how you're feeling today because i
think you have some kind of superpower
you were so calm
so cool so collected when that very
disturbing story broke
about the the plot to kidnap you
and possibly do you bodily harm what
were your thoughts as you watched what
was happening at the
state at the at the united states
capitol that day i
i was watching wondering what you were
thinking and feeling if you could share
that with us
well to listen to so many people say
they couldn't believe this was happening
it's been happening i've been trying to
get attention to this i've been trying
to call people
who hold office on both sides of the
aisle to talk about domestic terrorism
call it out for what it is i actually
asked the white house
i asked mike pence directly asked
republicans in my own state
i need we need to lower the heat it's
getting dangerous and then of course
there was that plot to kidnap and kill
me
this is the culmination of these things
and that's why
no matter if you're a democrat or
republican anyone who is a person of
good will
and has a platform needs to say domestic
terrorism will not stand
we have differences sure this is never
acceptable
you're right about that thank you very
much governor whitmer thank you